نحن الان نقف في منطقه دوار ابو مازن هذه
المنطقه التي دخلتها قوات الاحتلال للمره
الثانيه على التوالي وفي خلال دخولها له
هذه المنطقه عملت على دمار كبير وتجريف
لكن نشاهد المشهد بشكل اوسع في هذا الدمار
مسجد الامين محمد بالاضافه الى التجريف
الكبير في الشوارع المحاذيه لهذه المنطقه
هذا الشارع المطل على البحر لكن الملحوظ
ان هذه المنطقه واجهت مواجهات عنيفه ووجدت
في داخل هذه المنطقه بقايا اليات الاحتلال
تراكمه على الارض وهذه اثار المجنزرات
الاسرائيليه التي دخلت هذا المكان ايضا
هذه اثار بقايا اليات قوات الاحتلال التي
دخلت هنا يبدو انها تعرضت لمقاومه عنيفه
وشرسه وهذا ما تبقى من بعض الاليات
الاسرائيليه نرى في هذا
المشهد مكان تمركز ايضا الاليات
الاسرائيليه حيث عملت على
اي صناعه هذه الكثبان الرمليه لا يختصر
التدمير فقط على البنايات او الشوارع
حيث طال المؤسسات وطال جميع الاماكن في
هذا المكان هذه اثار القصف الاسرائيلي
تظهر بشكل واضح هذه الحفره الكبيره
الناجمه عن القصف الاسرائيلي العنيف لهذا
المربع دمار كبير
وتجريف في مكان تواجد قوات الاحتلال هنا
تظهر اثار تواجد قوات الاحتلال بشكل كثيف
جدا ويظهر بشكل واضح السوات الرمليه ايضا
التي تحصنت بها قوات
الاحتلال لكن الاوضح ان هذه المنطقه تعرضت
لدمار هذه البنايه التي احرقت ايضا بفعل
قوات الاحتلال وبقيت مشتعله لايام طويله
في هذا المكان يقع تجمع المدارس ومراكز
الايواء التي اقتحمتها قوات الاحتلال
واجلت جزء من العائلات الى المناطق
الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه قوات الاحتلال دمرت
هذه المباني بعد ان اقتحمتها واجلت عدد من
السكان بالاضافه الى سقوط عدد من الشهداء
والاصابات ممن كانوا نازحين داخل هذه
المدرسه نشاهد هذه مدرسه لولو عبد الوهاب
القطامي التي قصفت فيما قبل ووقع بها عدد
من الشهداء من عائله الكفارنه والمصري
وايضا مدرسه سعاد الصباح هي مجرفه بفعل
هذا الاحتلال هذه هيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه
والحريات التركيه دمرت بفعل قوات الاحتلال
تدمير مستمر وحرب مستمره على مدينه غزه
اسماعيل الغول الجزيره مدينه غزه